Speaker 1: Russia is now threatening American
assets in response to the first round of sanctions
to the first round of sanctions.
Let's start there.
Business Insider reporting.
Russia threatens to target sensitive U.S.
assets as part of a strong and painful response
to U.S.. Sanctions, its Foreign Ministry of
Foreign Affairs Ministry said the sanctions
were attempt to change Russia's course.
There should be no doubt that sanctions will
receive a strong response.
Russia's Foreign Affairs Ministry said the
country would target sensitive American assets
in retaliation.
The ministry said this is part of America's.
The sanctions are part of America's ongoing
attempts to change Russia's course.
Russia has proved that despite all the sanctions
cost, it is able to minimize the damage and
even more so, sanctions pressure is not able
to effect our determination to firmly defend
our interests, it added.
There should be no doubt that sanctions will
receive a strong response not necessarily
symmetrical, but finely tuned and painful
to the American side.
The United States, on the other hand, plans
to continue escalating the sanctions.
I don't even pretend to know where this will
end, but it is very clear that all along,
you know, we had we had reports which said,
here's what we know.
Here's what could happen.
And then here's a less bad scenario.
Just about every element of this so far has
been closer to the worst case scenario.
Now, obviously, there were people talking
about nuclear war as a worst case scenario.
I don't believe that will happen.
I don't believe we're going in that direction.
I think that that that's that's quite literally
it would be a suicide decision by Putin and
Russia.
But from from the sort of more reasonable,
could this be trying to take a little bit
of territory?
Could this escalate into bombing Kiev?
It's all going in the worst direction.
And economically, it's also already doing
significant, significant damage.
Understand also, by the way, that.
Russia has changed its tune on the sanctions
pretty quickly, I mean, just two days ago,
Russia was saying, we don't care about sanctions,
they're not really going to do anything.
Now Russia is saying the sanctions are painful
and we are going to retaliate specifically
for the sanctions.
So it should not be lost on us that Russia
has changed its opinion of the sanctions,
as stated.
So that's the latest that we know at this
point.
Within two hours, things may have changed.
We will, of course, be live later with the
latest, and you can find me on Twitter at
Packman and let me know your latest thoughts
on what's taking place.
The David Pakman Show depends on your support
to fund what we do the best way to do it,
the most direct way to support our work is
to get a membership on our website.
Join Packman Gqom.
You can use
the coupon code.
Wow.
22 for
a discount, if you so please.